hallo Thomas siehst du dich als
Einzelkünstler mit einer tollen Band
oder als Teil von der Band also ich sehe
mich als Teil von von aller Band nicht
als anskünstler ich mE man man hat jetzt
mich zwei im Fernsehen gesehen und man
mein Name ist bekannt geworden aber ich
bin ein Teil von einer Band hallo Thomas
mich würd interessieren wenn du an dem
Song arbeitest ist dann zuerst ein
fätzchen von der Musik da von der
Melodie oder erst vom Text und bei so
ein fast lyischen Text wie Schnee von
gestern kommt das mehr intuitiv oder
muss man an so einem Text vor allem hart
arbeiten dass der
besteht man hat so Textfragmente die
einem aus dem Alltag irgendwie
angeflogen kommen und die schreibt man
auf und
dann ja macht man wie so so ein
Brainstorming einfach und und und
versucht halt mit irgendwelchen Bildern
zu spielen und schreib halt auf manchmal
ist das halt manchmal hat man den Text
und versucht eine Melodie äh darauf
zuauen oder man hat auch mal nur eine
Melodie und versucht dann halt ein Text
drauf Z schreiben also das ist
verschieden